if you have ever found your guitar difficult
to play You're Not Alone In fact you might just
need a guitar setup when a guitar's action
is too high it's pretty much impossible to
play so action is the height of the strings
above the fretboard thankfully this type of
thing can be adjusted and in this video
we're going to teach you with the help
of our pro luthier your friend Marshall
Brune how to do a guitar setup at home
so Marshall lots of people find their guitars
difficult to play but don't even realize that
they can have it improved what type of things do
you do when someone takes their guitar to you and
says hey make this easier to play the first thing
I look at is the height of the string above the
first fret when this is depressed it should be the
same height over here so if it's more than that
it's going to be hard to play and most Factory
instruments are set up difficult to play because
they don't want them to buzz well the next step I
look at the Saddle the saddle is this white piece
of material here usually bone on cheaper guitars
this usually some type of synthetic material like
plastic and this can come out and you can also
change the size of it which changes the strings
on the bridge side that's right and so I will
also look and see how much saddle is left to go
down beyond that we're talking major surgery
so if your guitar doesn't pass this criteria
or this criteria I don't advise going any
further on your own then you need a marshall
but playability is so important and if you
watch our video that Marshall and I did
comparing guitars blindfolded you'll really get
a sense of how important playability is in fact
at some point I picked a guitar which was very
playable thanks to the work that Marshall did
on it which was only 300 over a guitar which cost
thousands of dollars which was badly in need of
a setup because I felt it fighting me so it's
the most important thing the playability and a
setup is what can get you to have that beautiful
easy to play guitar that's right you don't need
a fifteen thousand dollar guitar to play well you
just need a good setup so since playability is so
important in this video Marshall has generously
offered to show us what we can all do at home
using common household tools to make your guitar
more playable so should we go to the shop yeah
let's go all right you've seen a lot of Brandon's
videos on this guitar and he's played beautifully
but I think I can make this better first things
first I'm looking at the knot I'm looking at
the Saddle I want to see kind of How High the
action is as a whole so I'm seeing with these
gut strings which are exceptionally delicate that
there's a little bit of a sharp edge on this nut
so what I'm going to want to do is round that
over if need be and then from there I'm looking
at the action so on the sixth string three and
three quarters and then on the first string is
one two and three quarters so to the top of the
Fret to the underside of the string I think we
can get this down because I'm looking down the
neck and it's got a good curvature you don't
ever want to see a neck that's dead straight so
what I'm seeing is I can take down the saddle a
little bit and I can adjust the knot to the string
each string to make sure that it fits properly and
then once I do that I'm going to polish this up
and make sure that this string doesn't continue
to fray this is actually causing a very moderate
amount of falseness over the entire length of the
string so it may not be noticeable but it's there
so I'm going to just take down the the strings
all right so now that the strings are
completely loose I should be able to slip
the saddle right out these should never ever be
glued in if you glue in a saddle I'm coming for
you so I want to lower the action a little
bit use a hard service we're going to take
some 120 grit sandpaper and we're just going
to hold it down what we're gonna do is very
carefully make sure that saddle is balanced
across the bottom and since I want to lower
the base side of this a little bit more I'm gonna
grab it on the base side and just very carefully
stand back and forth in order to remove
the material now this material actually
does come off fairly quickly so be careful
we're going to just continue sanding through
this saddle a bit we don't want to take off too
terribly much because it's pretty close and that's
all that we need now we also want to make sure
that the bottom surface is square to each Edge
because if it's at this angle or at this
angle too much it's not going to make good
contact with the bottom of the saddle slot
so we're going to give this a try we took
off probably about a little bit over a quarter
of a millimeter which means it'll bring it down
about a tenth here which will make it noticeably
easier to play so we're going to just take that
slide it back in we'll give this a little quick
measure yeah that took it down to about 3.3
millimeters on the base string so that'll be
a lot nicer now this guitar I don't feel like
it needs any adjustment at the nut but if it's
too high again you could do the same technique
or if you've got a hobbyist set of files like this
you can use one of these to very carefully work
the nut very very carefully this is a hobbyist
file and it's got a nice grit on this corner
which is what you want to use so what I'm doing
right now is I'm looking at the very corner of
the the nut where it should be vibrating from
and I'm actually seeing that it's rounded this
way which a lot of companies like to do because it
looks it's very very nice but what it doesn't do
is go give a good Edge for the string to vibrate
from so you're actually losing sound if those are
too rounded over and you have a very Instinct
Edge for the string to roll on so again you
can see right here it's vibrating from here not
here and I'm not lowering the front of the slot
at all I'm just crisping up that edge seeing
it has a more distinct place to vibrate from
I'm not putting a whole lot of pressure onto
it I'm just putting enough to make sure that
it stays engaged okay so now that this has been
adjusted I'm going to want to polish this so in
order to do that I am going to employ the use of
a string and a little bit of car polish we're just
going to put a little tiny drop so you're going
to get your little inner shoe shine and going
and shoe shine this this way it's taking away
any and all rough edges and again this is a
smiled abrasive so you don't want to do this
too terribly much and what this is going to
do is Polish the inside of that slot so that way
we can remove any of these sharp edges that are
cutting Brandon's very expensive gut strings
so that's what you're going to do if your nut
is too high to the first fret you want to lower
the slots down and that is only to the first fret
it's not going to change anything Downstream on
the guitar so if your nut is too low and you're
constantly buzzing at your first string what you
want to do is to get a luthier approved business
card you can only use a luthier approved
business card and what you're going to do
typically it's the fifth and sixth string that are
going to be too low so you're going to just want
to bring it up ever so slightly and believe
it or not one of these normal business cards
is just the right thickness most of the time to
get things taken care of so I like to use this
ultra thin super glue for doing this operation but
you don't have to go out and buy this you can use
some regular old wood glue or if you're feeling
very creative and arts and craftsy you can just
cut out a piece of this and stick it under there
it's not going to affect the sound at all I can
promise you so normally I'm just going to glue
this in and then I use a knife to cut it out I
suggest just cutting it apart and putting one
or two pieces in if you get past two pieces of
shim material come see me or another luthier
who knows what they're doing okay after that
it starts to get ridiculous so yes you can put
a shim under here you can put a shim under here
99.999 times out of 100 you're not going to
hear the difference I can't and I suppose we've
established it I've got okay ears you could always
raise the action a little bit you can always drop
the action a little bit don't go overboard a
little piece of paper will do way more than you
think so at this point all we have to do is get
the nut back on you have to make sure that it's
like a ramp going to the front and likewise with
the saddle that it's a ramp going to the front
you don't want it to be backwards like
this because then I get people calling
me saying I have an intonation issue and it's
because they put the knot on backwards or the
saddle or both so make sure that it's going
the right way at this point in time this is
when I highly recommend putting a drop of three
in one oil onto your guitar what we're gonna do
is we're going to put a drop of oil right
where the worm meets the gear just one
drop on every roller once you have that on
you'll notice that your tuning machines run
a lot smoother and you've just increased the
lifespan of your tuning machines by a long time
you'd be amazed at how many tuning machines
wear out prematurely because they don't have
a drop of oil put on them once a year and at
that point your guitar is done that's the most
home setup that I would recommend doing beyond
that bring it by if you want to clean it up just
use a little bit of water and a cotton towel it's
that simple no waxes no polishes no moisturizers
rejuvenators none of that that's all going to
make my job harder if you ever have to bring it
in Marshfield thanks so much for being so generous
and helping out all of my YouTube followers and
showing them how they can do this at home this
has been super helpful oh you're welcome anytime
I'm happy to help and if any of you have any
questions feel free to reach out and contact me
off of my website and for 500 off use promo code
Brandon that's good for any new guitar and you
know I'll talk you through this if you have any
questions thanks Marshall thanks Brandon [Music]